[Music]
today's question comes from eric in
rhode island i'm 28 years old and i've
been living with my parents in the since
the pandemic began during this time i've
paid off over fifty thousand dollars in
student loans and a car loan however i
still have approximately seventy three
thousand left in student loans to pay
off i make a little over 65k a year at
my civilian employer and serve part time
in the national guard usually bringing
home 15k a year i'm afraid of moving out
of my parents place for two reasons one
i don't know how i will pay off my debt
in timely manner and two i fear the only
places i can afford will be undesirable
locations do you have any advice you
could offer me
yes
we do have advice that we can offer you
so you're 28 years old you're making 80k
a year and you've got 73 000 left in
student loans and you've already been
paying on you paid off over 50k
so you absolutely can pay off this debt
in a timely manner
uh the fear of living in an undesirable
location well you can quelch that by
getting a roommate and undesirable i can
handle undesirable if it means long-term
gain if it means i can get out of debt
faster now if you're talking about
unsafe that's a different story but if
it's just somewhere you wouldn't want to
live for a long time that's okay you're
not going to live there a long time
so you're going to live on nothing and
if if that means getting a roommate or
staying at your parents place i'm okay
with that i mean you can easily get out
you make 80 000 a year there's no reason
you need to live in their basement any
longer
but you can pay this thing off in 18
months two years max making what you
make so there's not really any excuses
here other than you know decision
paralysis
eric let's pretend that you're
we're going to fast forward way up into
your life and you have a daughter that
is 24 years old
and when you think of your daughter your
smile she's your little princess you've
raised her she's smart
she's self-sufficient
does she want to date you when you live
in your mother's basement
do you want her dating you if you're her
dad
answer is no
so go get you a place dude
you're 28 freaking years old
and you'll get out of debt you'll figure
it out people making eighty thousand
dollars pay off seventy 73 000 all the
time and they don't live with their
parents it works all the time
and you need to do that it's going to be
so good for you and it's going to be
good for your mom it's time she's ready
for you to leave
or your dad is or both of them are
um
they may be really ready for you to
leave i don't know but i don't know i
don't know it's just um
there's a developmental thing here that
is really good for you
and so yes it's going to slow down
mathematically your ability to get out
of debt is fast whoopty doopty and yes
making eighty thousand dollars a year
you can find a place in rhode island
tuesday i think you're gonna be okay
you're gonna make it but you need to get
out